so during this nine year journey and
you're writing these spec scripts
in your free time right where are you
finding that free time i realize you
have a family of obligations you also
have a job
well uh when i was unemployed because uh
uh not so not so much during the knott's
landing period it was before that
uh in fact this is very funny the the
the cheer script
that i wrote the first one that was too
dirty that according to the agent there
actually i got the idea for this script
because i was being an
absolute pain in the neck to my wife
because i was unemployed and we just had
a baby and i thought i was a failure and
i wasn't supporting my family
and we're actually having an argument
about this at 11 o'clock at night where
she says
you've got this free time why don't you
write something now and she said why
don't you rewrite
your feature script i said well i'm not
ready to do that she said well then
write a cheers episode
i said well i would but i haven't had
any ideas wait i just got an idea
it was bizarre in the middle of an
argument i went over my desk was
in our bedroom at that time was a table
a kitchen table it was in our bedroom
and i wrote notes and said okay i'll do
this starting tomorrow
and i wrote the script in a week and
then called up the agent and said okay
i've written another script
and it really got my agent interested in
representing me even though he had
reservations about that particular
script he clearly
said this guys can write comedy so that
that's what i did when i was unemployed
i would write it was too difficult to
write
with a family and a 12 hour a day job
but
but it was a job that had periods of
unemployment and so
i tried not to be lazy during those
times
well speaking of which how would you
motivate yourself because it's so easy
to have a grand plan like that
and it sounds great in theory but then
how did you actually execute it every
day what was your
what was your sort of disciplined uh i i
found and this is still true for me that
i worked best in the morning
and so i would get up and kind of
um a lot of times what helps me is to
exercise
and if i'm you know either jogging in
those days or now on an elliptical
machine in the
in the gym that time and taking a shower
and stuff
is really productive for me to think
about what i'm going to be doing
that day with my writing or to solve a
writing problem i'm having
so that when i hit the desk so to speak
i'm really hit at running and i've got
some momentum
and that that worked for me i also think
i just enjoyed writing i really
wanted to achieve this goal really badly
and and could see that others were
achieving it it wasn't like
you know i lived in los angeles so i i
could see people around me who were
breaking through
and i knew that it was possible and so i
just
kept at it but your your question is a
really good one because
you have to be disciplined one of the
great stories of discipline perhaps the
most disciplined writers
i ever heard of was a man named stephen
cannell passed away a few years ago
became incredibly successful i mean if
you could get a
show on tv you're successful if you get
multiple series on tv
that's beyond successful stephen cannell
created or co-created
40 television series 4-0
that's unbelievable he wrote or co-wrote
450 episodes of television i mean just
if just think about that i know that
just sounds like a large number but if
you write
15 scripts a year that get produced for
30 years
amazing stephen cannell came and spoke
to my students
several years ago and said i am severely
dyslexic i flunked out of the third
grade i flunked out of the eighth grade
if i can make it you can make it but his
key was he said i'm not the smartest guy
in the room i'm not the most talented
guy in the room
i'm the hardest working guy in the room
and when
camel got out of college he had a day
job at his family's furniture business
and then wrote from 5 p.m to 10 p.m
every day
monday through friday putting a full day
writing saturday and a half day sunday
he did this for six years until he got a
job and i'll never forget him saying
but the thing is at the end of every
year when i looked back
i was that much better and it was just
awe inspiring to hear him talk about
that
and he just he had to he had to keep
practicing
there's a theory in general not just
about writing but about any kind of
pursuit that it takes 10 000 hours
of practice to become an expert at
something
tennis piano computer programming
writing
uh that's a long time that's you know if
you practice 20 hours a week
for 50 weeks a year that's a thousand
hours so
my nine years probably was not too far
off what the
that metric was for getting good at it